hello glamour readers my name is Zoe and
I thought would be nice today to share
with you my new splash botanics Beauty
range this entire range is based on my
love of all things bow Tanic and also
features a very fresh scent which is
perfect for this time of year and I
think they go really nicely hand-in-hand
some of the notes are freesia jasmine
lotus blossom and also some osanic notes
which make it have that really nice
fresh summer scent first up is this
which is the drench mute bubble bath
soak this has coconut water and light
key in it which makes it really lovely
and moisturizing and this creates the
most epic bubbles this is the make
splash of moisturizing body wash we have
this in our other collection jelly and
gelato and so many people loved it that
we thought was only right to bring it
back I love using this to shave my legs
it's perfect it's very moisturizing and
means that you can jump out the shower
and if you're in a rush you don't need
to put your moisturizer on this has got
to be it one of my favorite products it
is the legume love bath milk powder I'm
really really excited about bath mat
powder at the moment it's basically in
every single bath I have it makes the
water really milky and it's really
softening and moisturizing on the skin I
just love it and it smells amazing this
is the quench me body moisturizing
sorbet we have never done a sorbet
formulation before so it's really really
exciting that we're able to bring this
out in this range I am obsessed with
this especially on very sunny days like
we've been having recently I hate when
you put moisturizer on and you have to
kind of wait for it to sink in which is
nice at nighttime but I think if you're
on the go and you need something that's
gonna sink him really quickly but also
is very refreshing and moisturizing at
the same time this is perfect and again
has the coconut water and the light key
which make it really lovely and
refreshing definitely been my go-to
summer staple this is the body mist
which is in the range and it's in this
lovely glass packaging much like all the
other body mists and again this has
notes of the Jasmine the freesia the
lotus blossom
and the O's onic notes as well it's
really fresh it's very uplifting and I
think it's perfect for this time of year
it's the scent that we've never really
done before and I think it has like the
perfect mixture of fresh and floral next
up is another formulation we've been
working on for a real long time and it's
so exciting they were able to talk about
this in the / botanics range and it is
the so soft lip oil I'm a huge lover of
liberals I think they're incredible
they're so nice to wear if you're not
really much of a lip gloss or lipstick
wearer this is definitely for you and
also nourishes the lips as well because
it has argan oil and jojoba oil and lots
of lovely things for your lips also
tastes and smells like cherries which
makes me so happy and tastes delicious
and last by no means least it is the
beautiful cosmetics bag which you can
throw all your makeup in you can take to
the pool you can use it for travel
keeping your handbag organized is a
really good size and it goes perfectly
with the rest of the collection the
range is available online and in store
at Superdrug and also available online
and feel unique thanks so much guys
enjoy the fun